- Well, your new show,
How I Met Your Father,
you work with Hilary Duff.
- Yeah.
- So y'all ever met before?
- (chuckles) Well,
speaking of learning new things
and being excited about it.
A friend of mine had just had
a baby about 10 years ago.
And I was hanging out with Haylie Duff.
She had guest starred
on Secret Life of the American
teenager when I was on it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So she invited me to
hang out with her
and she had to get something
from her mom's house
while Hillary was there
and she was pregnant
with her first child and
she was about to pop.
But like I said, my
friend had just had a baby
and I learned what a mucus plug was.
- Hmm.
- And so the first thing I asked-
- What's a Mucus Plug?
I've had babies.
- Girl you have babies and you don't know
what a mucus plug is.
- No.
- Yeah apparently when
you pee it like comes out
and it's like the sign-
- Oh! Oh-
- that you're about to go into labor.
- I had C-sections.
- Oh, okay.
- That sounds disgusting.
- Well, I did and I,
that's the first thing I asked Hillary,
like, "Hi, nice to meet you.
Did your mucus plug fall out yet?"
- No, you didn't.
- I was so excited to learn something new
and I didn't under-
I was so nervous, it was
Hillary Duff. (audience laughs)
- Oh my God I love you so much. You just-
- Oh my-
- You're kind of like
me and just comes out.
Information comes out and
you're like, "Why did I say it?"
- Yeah, pretty much and I
just, you know, I was like,
I made that choice-
- I do that.
I'm just going to keep going
and she laughed and she was like,
"No, thank you for asking."
- So wait, a mucus-
"Thank you for asking?"
She's polite. (Laughs)
- Well, I mean, we talked about it.
- "Thank you for asking
about my mucus plug"
- And she was 24, so she was like,
"I was just excited that someone my age
knew what that was cause no one"-
- Is that what plugs the baby up in there?
Like when it comes out,
it's like ready time?
- Yes, ready time
- Oh, go time. Okay.
- You're close
- See? I've had two babies, did not know.
You just taught me something.
Thank you.
- You're welcome, See?
- Yes.
- See guys? You See?
- You are, you're an educator
- And I've never had a kid.